This question from the WhatsApp Nanjiba
from Bangladesh. If someone promises to
Allah that he will not commit such and
such a sin, he did that and he makes an
unreal promise to Allah which he cannot
keep. What should he do? And if a
student observes three fasts in the name
of Allah as an experation for breaking
an oath and if he hears from many that
10 poor people should be fed or clothed.
If he also promises Allah that he will
clothe or food give clothes or food to
10 poor people for all the promises he
has made to Allah in his life which you
could not keep and he breaks his oath.
Now he has to give clothes of food to 10
poor people as expression for breaking
the same oath again. Nanjiba for
Bangladesh is that if someone promises
to Allah and does not keep that promise
what should he do here you have to make
a differentiation between a promise to
Allah and an oath to Allah there's two
difference when you promise something it
is you're telling Allah okay I will do
this I will do that that's different
than taking an oath if you take an oath
it should have certain clause like how
Allah takes an oath of fig Allah takes
an oath of alasa
Al fajar then then of the mountains. So
when you take an oath, you take oath of
something and taking oath is of
different types. What scholars say that
so promise is something else that okay I
promise that I will do something and
that I promise I'll be good. I promise
I'll be truthful. That's different. I'm
making a commitment to Allah. But taking
oath is different. An oath normally the
prophet said
always said there are many say you said
that the prophet discouraged us from
taking oaths. Oath means you said that
if I pass the examination I will go for
or if I pass the examination I'll give
charity of $1,000 to the poor people. So
this type of oath the prophet
discouraged. It says that taking oath
does not change the it only makes a
miser person give in charity. So when
you're taking an oath there are
different types of oath. Some oaths
which are good to take some oath which
are not good to take some ammo. The oath
that if you ask and you take an oath of
Allah that if so and so thing happens I
will do this sort of worship it's not
encouraged it's not haram because you
are putting a stipulation to Allah that
okay if I pass the examination I will
pray to I'll go for that and if you do
that act if you pass the examination it
is as though you are forced to do it
you're not doing it out of your own
favor that's one of the reason is that
as though you're buttering with Allah
that if my sickness is cured, I will go
for if my sickness is cured, I will fast
10 days or whatever it is. So the
prophet said the is not changed. So what
is going to happen? You won't happen.
What's written in your destiny will
happen. So if you take an oath with
bering something with Allah, it's not
encouraged in Islam. It's not haram, but
it's not encouraged. The prophet said it
only makes a miser person give charity.
So maider person say that okay if I get
healthy I will give $1,000. Okay the m
person doesn't give charity so at least
he'll give $1,000. So the prophet
personally prefer give charity. Okay
I've decided I'll give charity today
$1,000. Very good. I decide I'll give
char 2,000. Very good. But if you say I
will pass then I'll give charity. It's
not encouraged. So oath means you are
parting something. If this thing happens
I'll do this. So these sides of oath
Allah says in the Quran in surah Maida
chapter number 5 verse number 89 that
that if the oath is unintentional Allah
will forgive it but if it's an
intentional oath then if you do not keep
it if you do not fulfill the oath give a
kafara kafar mean give kafar give
experation of feeding 10 poor people,
miskin people, and feed them the same
way how you feed your family. So if
you're a rich person and you spend maybe
$100 on per meal, so feed 10 people with
$100 each. If you're a poor person who
feeds maybe $1 per meal, so feed 10
people with $1 or clothe 10 people, same
how you clothe a family or free a slave.
So this is a condition put by Allah
subhanaa tala in surah maida chapter
number 5 verse number 79 that if it un
Allah will forgive you but it is
intentional and if it is all done by you
and if you not fulfill it feed 10 people
poor people how you feed your family or
clothe 10 people or you free a slave if
you cannot do this then you fast for
three consecutive days. So if you make
an oath the best the prophet said is do
it as long as the oath is not a haram
oath. Now there are some oaths which are
haram. For example, you say that I will
go to da and put 10 candles on the da.
So this is wrong. Or if you say that I
have taken an oath or done commitment.
One is a commitment, one is a promise
the difference. And if you say that if
this things happen, I'll do this. If
this thing happen, I do idol worship.
Idolid worship is haram. So anything you
say if I pass the examination I will do
idol worship. Idol worship is haram. So
in these conditions if you commit if you
take an oath of doing a sin then the
prophet said don't do the sin give the
kaf. So if you have given an oath to
commit a sin or given a promise to
commit a sin don't do that sin do a
kafara or feeding 10 people or clothing
10 people or freeing a slave. If you
cannot afford it then you can fast for
three consecutive days. There are some
things which is not a sin but you can't
afford to do. You say that if I pass the
examination I will give $10,000 charity.
You don't even earn $1,000. I will give
$10,000. Suppose you say that if I pass
the exam I'll go for Hajj and you're
sick that hell doesn't permit you. So if
you make an oath which you cannot
fulfill it's not a haram oath. Going to
h is good. Giving 10,000 charity is
good. So then you give kaf that is feed
10 people. poor people equivalent to how
you feed your family or clothe 10 people
or free of slave. If you can't afford
this, then fast three consecutive days.
So one oath which haram you should not
do it only give kafara. One oath is
which you have committed but you cannot
do it because you can't afford to do it
or you're not healthy, you don't have
the money. Then the third type is which
is moua. Okay, if I pass I will give
charity and you have the money then you
give charity. This is optional. One
thing is there which is oaths which are
good that you as you have said you'll do
this without putting a condition to
Allah subhana wa t'ala I have I have
committed to Allah that this year I'll
give charity of $10,000 and your
business goes down is good it's not
against anything it's not saying that
only if this happened you have given a
commitment you have given to Allah that
this thing I will do this year and your
business goes down so you had the
intentions so if you're given those and
your business goes down. You cannot give
$10,000. Okay, feed 10 people, can't
feed 10 people, clothe 10 people or free
a slave. Cannot do this fast three. So,
one is something which is haram, you
should not do it. Give one is you have
said something, you don't have the
capacity. One is you had the capacity
but then the business didn't go well. So
at that time the best is to fulfill the
oath. Whatever oath you have given to
Allah unless it's a sin, unless it's
haram, best is to fulfill. You cannot
say if you have the money, your business
is done very well. You promised $10,000.
Why give $10,000? Feeding 10 people will
only cost me $100, cost me only $200.
Why give $10,000? So this is wrong. The
prophet said if your business is done
well, if you have given oath, fulfill
the oath first. If you cannot then the
kafar is there. Or if it's a oath which
is committing a sin. So you have to
differentiate between this. So based on
all this the answer is very clearcut
that if you promise something if it's
not a sin you have to do it and then
again the question has asked that he has
made many promises he hasn't fulfilled
for each promise he hasn't fulfilled he
has to either feed 10 people or he has
to each oath that he has taken if he
doesn't fulfill either feed 10 people or
clothe 10 people or feed a slave or
three consecutive days so then if he
says Okay, I will feed 10 people or
clothe 10 people or fast three and he
doesn't do this also. So if he has not
done 10 oath he hasn't kept and this
11th one. So he has to give 11 times to
10 people. You can't say only once is
sufficient. No, if he cannot afford it
at least he should fast for each oath
three days. So if 10 pro 10 oath he has
taken and he has not fulfilled it then
he has to fast 10 into three 30 three
consecutive days if you want to take a
gap take a gap again three consecutive
days and the last one which he did he
did not fulfill again he has to fast
another for that so for every oath that
or commitment you have given to Allah
subhanana wa tala there's a difference
you should understand that that I will
not do a sin
You're telling Allah that's different
than doing an oath and a commitment. So
both are different. So if you have given
an oath and a commitment then you have
to fulfill can't fulfill then is a hope
that answers the question.